- [Narrator] It would be
so hard to go back home
after everything happened and try
to just live your life normally.
I think that's partially why my family
just chose not to really talk about it.
They just wanted to
leave it all in the past.
(emotional music)
- During World War II
Manzanar was an American
incarceration camp in which
Japanese Americans were
held against their will in
the name of national security.
- I want to go to Manzanar
because I don't think
I know my own history that well.
Both of my grandparents were held
in camps when they were children.
- My family didn't really
talk about it growing up.
Whenever I'd ask about
it like my grandparents
were too young to remember
and they said that
they never talked about
it with their parents.
- My family was actually not in the camps.
It was more like just remember,
this is also something
that happened here in
California which I am born
and raised in California.
- I want to come out of this you know
more knowledgeable but also
I want to come out of this
with a greater understanding
of what happened.
I want to understand what it felt like
and understand what
they had to go through.
- Something like the story of the camps,
like visiting the camps, being there,
talking to people about
it like amongst ourselves
as Japanese Americans,
understanding our own story,
is so key 'cause we're
not going to be able
to move forward if we don't
know where we came from.
- When the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor,
our west coast became a
potential combat zone.
Living in that zone are
more than 100,000 persons
of Japanese ancestry.
Military authorities therefore determined
that all of them, citizens and aliens
alike would have to move.
The evacuees cooperated wholeheartedly.
The many loyal among
them felt that this was
a sacrifice they could make
in behalf of America's war effort.
(gentle guitar music)
- The air felt clean, but also like
you're in the middle of nowhere.
Like almost like placelessness.
- It's very hot.
- It's a little hot.
All things considered here.
- This amazing amazing
ranger comes to meet us,
and she ushers us over to the barracks.
- A lot of Manzanar is gone, so most of
the original buildings are gone.
Manzanar wouldn't even
be here for us to visit
if it weren't for the
efforts of Japanese Americans
who made the pilgrimage back to the site
and then who successfully
lobbied the government
to preserve it.
- These barracks have been
rebuilt in the same spot
that the ones were during World War II.
The barracks here were
100 feet by 20 feet.
When you got here.
- Their immediate reaction
is this is too nice.
- There's just like bunch of Japanese
slash Japanese Americans that were
squished into a very small space.
I can't imagine.
- Not comfortable.
When they came here,
how long were they told
they were going to be staying?
- That must be tough to not be able
to tell your kids how long
they have to expect to stay.
- I just kept thinking
about the first night.
Imagine the first night
walking into this barrack.
Imagine the first night with your suitcase
just like unpacked at
the foot of your bed,
unsure how long you're gonna be there.
- We went outside, and
while we were on the grounds
we did notice that there
were like basketball courts.
- This basketball court has been redone,
but it is historically correct.
- Seeing the basketball hoops there
just proves that despite all the injustice
and things that were
being placed upon them,
they didn't let it break their spirit.
Ball was still life, which
is like super dope to me.
- We went into the visitor's center
and that was really fascinating obviously
seeing like all the
propaganda from the time.
- It was from a nationally
syndicated columnist
who said "herd 'em up, pack 'em off
"and give 'em the inside
room in the Badlands.
"Let 'em be pinched, hurt,
hungry and dead up against it.
"Personally I hate the Japanese,
"and that goes for all of 'em."
- The ranger took out these family records
for those of us who had families
that were put in the camps.
- [Woman] Oh that's so cool.
- This list where the family's from,
part of California, and this list
where they're heading to where after
they leave camp, where they're going.
And if you look at, this is all my family.
Chicago, Illinois, Chicago,
Illinois, Chicago Illinois.
I mean they made it there
because that's where I'm from.
- Seeing it on paper and
seeing like the actual record,
like that's like a piece of my family's
history right there you know?
Like an artifact.
- Sean, I found both your
grandparents block addresses
which if we want to try and go see them,
I would probably have
better luck than you did.
- [Woman] So block five is?
- Is the one where Paul was, yeah.
- [Woman] And Paul is Sean,
Paul is your grandfather?
(emotional music)
This is where my grandpa's barrack was.
So yeah.
- [Woman] And now you're here.
- Now I'm here.
- They hadn't excavated the
site, so our park ranger
told us that the plate had probably been
at that barrack site for over 70 years.
- We're gonna put it back.
- [Patricia] Yes.
The morning before we went to Manzanar
was the first time that my
grandfather forgot my name,
and so to be at Manzanar the next day
and to see his barrack, I think for me
it was like survivors of the camps
can't be the only ones telling the story
because they're fading,
but for us to make sure
that the lessons continue, we have to keep
going back to the camps whether
literally or figuratively,
'cause there's so much to learn.
- It looks like...
- This is definitely, I told
you it was a sewer pipe!
- 'Cause the diameter's
too big, so water coming in
has to be in pressure, so
you get those smaller lines.
- I am probably holding a sewage pipe.
(gentle guitar music)
- We went to the cemetery,
and that was just
very like peaceful and serene.
- It's just covered in these
like colorful origami cranes,
and there is this like windstorm blowing
and it was like blowing the cranes.
- The whole thing in general was actually
a lot more emotional for me
than I thought it would be.
I thought I would see it, you know,
from like a historical perspective.
I didn't expect it to
affect me like it did.
- When you learn something about a tragedy
the next step is sort of like
oh, what work can be done in order
to apply the lessons from camp?
- And there's like this real danger
that this same rhetoric
is going to get out there
and that people are going to be
arbitrarily sent off for no reason.
- Just imagine someone just telling you
to pack your bag and leave right now.
- And it's nobody's duty
to read every textbook
and take every Asian
American studies course
and learn everything, just showing up
it's not like saving the world,
but I think that it's, by knowing more
and by learning more
and by gaining knowledge
and building a perspective,
we're ultimately
contributing to a larger consciousness.
(gentle guitar music)